human beings are endowed with this
miracle of self reference we call it
consciousness this capacity to be
self-aware to reflect upon ourselves now
consciousness remains a mystery the
question of course is can consciousness
be reduced to a pattern of information
right I mean our cells turn over all the
time apparently something like every 7
years we are an entirely new organism
yet something persists the pattern
persists and if consciousness can be
reduced to just being a pattern of
information then it raises the question
of whether or not we can substitute our
biological substrate for an alternative
housing for our consciousness so the
idea of mind uploading would be a form
of technologically mediated immortality
right I mean at the end of the day Eric
Davis says we are algorithmic cascades
of data we are information our genes our
little software programs we are made of
language we are alphabetic beings all
the way down and the fact that real
thinkers right people like Ray Kurzweil
and other renowned future is are
entertaining the notions of mind
uploading is something that is feasible
then perhaps immortality is within our
grasp
perhaps in the words of Robert Edgar and
the merchants of immortality together we
shall drink the wine of centuries unborn
right we're talking on the back of our
own ingenuity our technology our
capacity to reduce ourselves to data
that we will transcend the forces of
entropy
Buckminster Fuller famously said life is
anti-entropic it is our role to go again
entropy to move towards greater
complexity in organization and I believe
transcending the limits of mortality
transcending a biological housing is
part of our destiny it is our birthright
and I say we make it happen